the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones season
8 video
in this video i want to discuss what i
believe was a missed opportunity by the
game of thrones writers dan and dave
as you all know during the season 8
finale we saw
jon snow stab and killed daenerys
targaryen while they were standing in
front of the iron throne
that made a lot of fans angry for many
different reasons
now maybe there is nothing they could do
to fix that scene for some of you
but i think there is something they
could have done to make it better
in season 7 they foreshadowed something
that would have made dany's death have a
much bigger impact
i don't know how all of you felt but
when jon killed danny
i did not really feel anything at all in
fact
if i did feel anything it would have
been frustration because of the way
things were handled in the final season
however i think there is one way they
could have made that scene so much more
emotional
not only for the fans but for jon snow's
character as well
now this might only be my opinion but i
think they should have done this either
while daenerys was pregnant with jon
snow's child
or after daenerys already had their
child let me explain what i mean
ever since the very first season of the
show we have been led to believe that
daenerys cannot have children
this is what mary masder implied after
daenerys lost her first child
that's why dany always said the dragons
will be the only children she'll ever
have
however once season 7 came out it
started to seem like they were
foreshadowing john and daenerys having a
child together
in fact i would even say it was obvious
because they foreshadowed it so many
times
but it must have been another example of
the writers subverting expectations
again
they set this up three different times
in season 7 episode 6
which was the episode right before john
and danny had sex
when jon went out beyond the wall to
capture a white he wanted to give
longclaw back to jorah mormont so that
it could stay in his family
but as you all know jorah would not
accept the sword
he told jon to keep it he said it will
serve you well
and your children after you i've
forfeited the right to claim this song
it's yours it'd serve you well
and your children after you
you could see that john actually
considered what he said
john was always concerned about having
any children because he did not want
them to grow up as a bastard like he did
but for the first time in the show we
see john think about that possibility
this made me wonder if jon did have any
children
who would he have them with it did seem
like danny would be the obvious answer
if anyone at all
however later in this same episode we
are reminded that danny cannot have any
children
this happens when daenerys and tyrion
are having a conversation about
succession
on dragonstone tyrion is worried about
what would happen to westeros after dany
died
after you break the wheel how do we make
sure it stays broken
you want to know who sits on the iron
throne after i'm dead
is that it you say you can't have
children
but there are other ways of choosing a
successor he thinks it would just go
back to the way it has always been
now these scenes about john and danny
having children may not seem like
anything right now
but this is brought up again and again
in this same season
at the end of this episode after dany's
dragon dies
we hear her mention this to jon she says
the dragons are the only children she'll
ever have
[Music]
the dragons are my children
they're the only children i'll ever have
do you understand
this is when it became obvious that john
and danny were starting to fall for each
other
so it was very interesting that this
continued to get mentioned right before
they were about to have sex
then in the very next episode it did
seem like they were foreshadowing it
again
when john and danny went to king's
landing to meet cersei there was a
moment when jon hands danny
a piece of baby dragon skull i thought
that was definitely symbolizing
jon given danny a baby dragon of their
own and by baby dragon
i of course mean a baby targaryen but
then jon says something else that was
very interesting
and it also made a lot of sense once
again danny mentioned she cannot have
any children
john says well who said that then danny
says mary master
so john basically says why would you
believe her
and your family hasn't seen it's end
you're still here i can't have children
who told you that the witch who murdered
my husband
as it occurred to you she might not have
been a reliable source of information
i do have to say john made a lot of
sense right there
why would we all automatically assume
mary masdar was right about danny not
having children
when you look at all the scenes i showed
you it honestly felt like they were
setting up john and danny having a child
together
now in my opinion i think they made a
big mistake
not having that happen i think it would
have made dany's death
so much more emotional it would have
made it an even harder choice for john
to kill her as well
since dany killed innocent women and
children in king's landing
we could all find ways to justify why
john had to kill her
but it would have been very difficult to
think of a way to justify john killing
her
while she was pregnant they also could
have done this another way
they could have had john kill her after
she already had the child as well
either way her death would have had a
much bigger impact on us as an audience
and on jon as a character he would have
had to live with that for the rest of
his life
the whole time leading up to that scene
we would have thought
there is no way jon will kill the mother
of his child
ned stark would never do something like
that so we would assume
jon would not either but can you just
imagine if he did
imagine if he had to make that choice it
would have been so much more devastating
like i said at the beginning of the
video i did not feel anything when jon
killed danny at the end of season 8
and i know i'm not the only one who felt
this way either i have seen hundreds or
even thousands of fans say the same
thing
it was so rushed it was hard to feel
anything at all
after they made danny go crazy and burn
down king's landing
we all knew that john had to kill her it
was so obvious by then
but if dany would have been carrying
their child or if this would have
happened shortly after she had their
child
it would have been shocking i know i
would have felt bad for all of them
not only john but danny and the baby as
well obviously
but i don't know maybe this sounds too
dark for some of you
but i think it would have added so much
more to that scene
you also have to think about what this
would have done to tyrion
psychologically
remember he's the one who basically
convinced john to go kill her
now imagine if tyrion knew that danny
was pregnant we all know how he wanted
to help save a sister because she was
now pregnant again
imagine if tyrion had to convince john
to kill dany
knowing she was the mother of his child
if that doesn't have an effect on you
then i don't know what will as i said
before they already had all this set up
by the end of season 7.
i think they made a big mistake by not
following through
let me know your thoughts on this what
would you have done to make danny's
death scene better
do you agree with what i said or am i
crazy for wanting to add a baby to the
mix
leave your thoughts down below in my
next video i will be discussing ned
stark's first chapter in a game of
thrones and after that
i will make a video on fire and blood to
help us get ready for house of the
dragon
i would love to see you all come back
for those as well anyways i want to
thank all of you for your support
i really appreciate that have a great
day everyone i will see you again very
soon
bye
[Music]
you